al día siguiente en la ciudad de
marsella donde el candidato de
izquierdas onic meloso encabezó los
resultados con un 31% la descripción es
palpable y hitman culé extraer máncora
estoy muy enfadado muy enfadado estamos
en una situación catastrófica en este
país algunas personas no han elegido una
voz para el progreso y la solidaridad
estoy extremadamente decepcionada lo
esperaba un poco pero tenía muchas
esperanzas de que los márgenes eran muy
estrechos así que estoy muy decepcionado
en la región de parís -1 también quedó
en primer lugar y algunos votantes se
han sentido desilusionados y eso posee
luego ayer pensábamos que ella luc
mélenchon iba a estar en la segunda
vuelta y que sería nuestro nuevo líder
pero no es así lo superaremos pero es
cierto que estamos un poco perdidos a
casi 7.000 kilómetros de distancia en
guadalupe hubo conmoción cuando se
anunciaron los resultados porque melón
había obtenido más de la mitad de los
votos en la isla no estamos
representados en los resultados
nacionales no nos sentimos escuchados y
es una verdadera pena es una gran
decepción para nosotros el domingo por
la noche en parís estos votantes de -1
salieron a la calle para expresar su
oposición a marín lópez serán clave para
saber quién se convierte en presidente
en la segunda vuelta electoral muchos
están indecisos prefiero quedarme en
bajo mi edredón y evitarlo todo no
saldré a votar de nuevo no tiene sentido
uno u otro son lo mismo los votos
cruciales de menos aún podrían ir a
cualquiera de los dos candidatos